احداث القضيه تعود الى اكتوبر من عام 2016
التقى المطرب المغربي سعد المجرد بفتاه
شابه تدعى لورا في منها ليلي بباريس
وتبعته الى مقر اقامته في فندق
وحتى هذه النقطه كانت الروايتان متطابقتان
الجزء الثاني من روايه اختلف حيث اتهمت
المدعيه المطرب المغربي في الجلسات
السابقه بضربها بشكل عنيف ومفاجئ ثم
اغتصابها حيث كانت تحت تاثير الكحول ومخدر
الكوكيين لكنها نجحت في صدده وغادرت
الغرفه في حاله صدمه ودعم روايتها شهدت
موظفي الفندق والتحليل النفسي الذي خدعت
له
لمجرد على الجانب الاخر نافع بشده ممارسه
اي علاقه مع لورا واقر فقط بانه دفع
واجهها بقوه بعد ما خرجته كرد فعل طبيعي
لكن المحكمه اعتبرت ان تصريحته متغيره
ومتبدله بعكس المدعيه فعلى سبيل المثال لم
يكن هناك خدش على ظهره كمتعه
القضيه اودع على خلفيتها لمجرد في السجن
لسته اشهر قبل اطلاق سراحه في ابريل 2017
كما سجينا في 2018 ايضا بعد اذنته باغتصاب
فتاه اخرى في بلده سنتربل الفرنسيه والتي
من المتوقع ان يمثل على اثرها امام محكمه
الجنايات في منطقه
[موسيقى]